ce que je retiens d'aimé césaire c'est
tellement difficile de dire en quelques
minutes mais je dirai ce qui m'a touché
le plus profondément c'est d'une part la
vision la clairvoyance la fulgurance
concernant la création du sermac parce
que ce n'était pas seulement une
position culturel c'était une réponse
politique à la situation d'un martinique
à un moment donné et qui faisait qu'il
fallait donner une réponse et la culture
a été cette réponse là parce qu'elle a
permis à des gens à des jeunes de toutes
générations de tout milieu social
d'accéder gratuitement à plis
constituait la plus fondamentale de
notre culture
il faut qu on se souvient de ce qu était
la martinique hameau de cette culture
dominante ou il n'était pas possible de
vraiment valoriser notre patrimoine et
ce faisant et maintenant vous a en même
temps ouvert sur le monde avec l'afrique
du sud avec les états unis
donc tout cela c'est important et je
retiens également la pensée politique
cette fois qu'il a eu le questionnement
à savoir qu est-il possible de faire
à des pays qui ont été colonisés quelle
est la réponse que l'on doit apporter ou
qu' il n'y ait pas de dictature ou qu'il
n'y ait pas de tyrannie pour que la
démocratie continue à s'exercer
cette réponse elle est toujours
d'actualité et on cherche encore la
réponse
donc le questionnement d'aimé césaire
est toujours moderne et il a tant qu' il
n'y ait d'autres qui prennent le
flambeau afin de donner parce que moi de
martini mais à tous les pays qui ont
connu la dictature qui ont connu la
colonisation
la façon à la fois d'être maîtres de
leur destin mais de respecter l'ensemble
de la population pour lui permettre
d'exercer ses droits